Hallo, Leute, ich bin am Start.
Eigentlich war es heute nicht geplant.
Ich wollte jetzt auf 3-4 Stunden Baldur's Gate spielen.
Da hab ich überlegt, okay, also ich hab halt schon ein bisschen gespielt.
Da hab ich überlegt, okay, warum machen wir nicht einfach streamen?
Weil ich hab gestern gesagt, heute gibt's streamen.
Und, naja, ich kann mir jetzt ja nicht irgendwelchen Technik-Gram aus den Fingern saugen,
wenn ich keinen Bock drauf hab und auch noch nicht weiß, was ich machen soll.
Deswegen hab ich gedacht, hey, komm, ich lass uns einfach ein bisschen zusammen weiterspielen.
Ich bin Mitte Akt 2 und ich bin mir nicht sicher, könnt ihr euch aussuchen,
ob ich Mainquest weitermachen soll.
Aber ich würd vorher noch ein bisschen Sidequests grinden,
weil ich müsste auch demnächst Level 8 sein.
Also noch 1-2 Quests oder 1-2 Fights, da müsste ich Level 8 sein.
Das ist natürlich extremly POG, weil auf Level 8 gibt es neue Feats, neue Attributpunkte und neue Spell Slots.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, weil ich sagen muss,
ich glaube, Leute, die jetzt nicht so Dungeons & Dragons affin sind,
die sind glaube ich etwas enttäuscht von der Character Progression in Baldur's Gate 3.
Weiß nicht, vielleicht ist ja einer von euch am Start,
der da im Vorfeld gar nicht so drin war und Baldur's Gate 3 gespielt hat.
Die Character Progression ist ziemlich mau, wenn man das Dungeons & Dragons 5th Edition System nicht mag.
Weil eigentlich passiert bei den Level Ups so gut wie nix.
Die einzigen Klassen, wo nennenswert was passiert jedes Level Up, sind Caster.
Und da eigentlich auch nur hauptsächlich Wizard und Sorcerer.
Bei den anderen tut sich alle 2-3 Level mal was.
Mal ein Feat auswählen, mal irgendwie ein bisschen was vergeben.
Es ist nicht viel.
Also ich glaube, dass einige Leute wirklich von der Character Progression enttäuscht sein könnten in dem Game.
Ich mag es persönlich.
Generell, ich mag ja auch das Regelwerk an sich.
Wobei man sagen muss, Baldur's Gate 3 hat da sehr viele Freiheiten.
Und auch ein paar Bugs, die so wenig Sinn ergeben.
Aber gut, es ist wie es ist.
Die haben sich dafür entschieden, das so umzusetzen.
Dafür gibt es auch ein paar coole Sachen, was abweicht von Dungeons & Dragons.
Also beispielsweise, dass so gut wie jeder Charakter easy Zugang zu Mystic Step hat.
Und du halt super mobil bist.
Sogar mit deinen Tanks und so.
Steinadler5, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also Leute, ich bin mit der Akt 2.
Ich habe noch nicht so viel aufgedeckt von der Map.
Also ich habe Akt 1 wirklich alles durchgespielt.
Ich habe Underdark durchgespielt, ich habe das Kloster durchgespielt.
Das Kloster habe ich übrigens zum Einsturz gebracht am Ende.
Das Kloster durchgespielt, alles von Akt 1, Quests erfüllt.
Also Akt 1 ist komplett abgeschlossen.
Da gibt es gar nichts mehr offen.
Und Akt 2 bin ich gerade so in der Mitte, würde ich sagen.
Also ich habe von der Map schon ein bisschen was aufgedeckt.
Hier unten irgendwo ist die Mainquest.
Ich glaube, das ist die Mainquest.
Nur Gaming-Stream heute.
Vielleicht gucken wir am Ende noch ein paar YouTube-Videos.
Mal gucken.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich 2-3 Stunden noch Ballos Gate 3 spielen.
Und das Ganze Off-Stream.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, warum mache ich es nicht auf Off-Stream an.
Wir machen jetzt wie gesagt ein bisschen Side-Quests.
Wir machen jetzt die Side-Quests hier.
Weil dann sind wir Level 8, hoffe ich.
Und wenn wir Level 8 sind, ich mache übrigens mal die Musik aus.
Weil das ist nicht Ballos Gate 3 Musik.
Das ist Kingmaker.
Das ist auch so ein Punkt, wo ich finde,
da hätten sie bei Ballos Gate 3 durchaus noch eine Schippe drauflegen können.
Ich meine, es ist bei dem Game allgemein Mecklern auf hohem Niveau.
Der Soundtrack hat ein paar coole Stücke.
Also beispielsweise eines der Boss-Battle-Themes ist sehr nice.
Aber insgesamt ist der Soundtrack doch sehr unauffällig.
Deswegen, ich habe mich jetzt schon...
Wobei ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, das werden Modgels fixen.
Es gibt ja schon ein paar Mods für Ballos Gate 3.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es ein paar Mods gibt, die Musikstücke aus anderen Games reinpatchen.
Weil ansonsten...
Ich meine, guckt mal hier.
Es gibt halt einfach ein bisschen Hintergrund.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube Soundtrack-mäßig hätte man noch ein bisschen was drauflegen können.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, auch wenn es glaube ich weniger Stücke hatte,
fand ich Ballos Gate 2 beispielsweise deutlich einprägsamer vom Soundtrack her.
Und ansonsten, also ich habe ein bisschen meine Party gewechselt im Vergleich zum letzten Mal.
Hat sich aber nicht allzu viel geändert.
Ich habe immer noch Will am Start.
Übrigens mein Main-Charakter ist Gale.
Aber Gale hat so...
Gale habe ich die Punkte-Respect, das ein bisschen optimierter für Wizard ist.
Und dementsprechend hat er noch 8 Charisma.
Ich glaube, wenn man den Charakter auswählt, dann hat der eigentlich 12.
Was aber komplett verschwendet ist auf dem Wizard.
Dann lieber mehr Int und ein bisschen mehr Con und plus auf Dex und sowas.
Deswegen habe ich Will am Start, weil Will ist halt der Charismatische.
Und der ist gut, wenn er vorläuft und alle Gespräche initiiert.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal Licht auf uns casten, bevor wir hier rauslaufen.
Was langer Lachs.
Ich hoffe übrigens, die Lautstärke ist okay.
Es ist immer so ein Ding bei Games und Windows.
Da ändert sich im Hintergrund auch manchmal was und dann stimmt es wieder nicht.
Ich glaube, ich hatte Level Up, seit ich das letzte Mal da war.
Und die ganzen Händler restocken ihr Inventar.
Ne, das hatte die das letzte Mal auch schon.
Ich dachte eigentlich, die Händler restocken ihr Inventar, wenn man Level Up hatte.
Aber die hatte den gleichen Krempel das letzte Mal auch schon.
Das Schild wäre, glaube ich, ganz gut für Shadowheart.
Aber nachdem ich noch kein einziges Schild plus eins gesehen habe in dem Game,
ist es eigentlich fast egal, was man für Schilder nimmt.
Ja, ich habe lieber ein Schild, was mich selbst heilt.
Weiß nicht, das bringt es nicht so wirklich.
Wobei das halt nicht verkehrt ist.
Einmal freie Cool Peel.
Aber Reaction brauche ich.
Naja, brauchen wir nicht.
So, da wollen wir mal los.
Also, wir müssen noch mit dem Schmied reden und dann gehen wir hier zur Sidequest.
Ja, ich habe meine Party ein bisschen umgestellt vom letzten Mal.
Das letzte Mal hatte ich Will, Gale, Shadowheart.
Ich meine, seriously, ohne die zwei kannst du eigentlich nicht spielen.
Egal wie, ich glaube, das müssten auch mit die meistgespielten Charakter sein.
Und dann brauchst du halt einen Tank.
So.
Und nachdem ich keine Barbarians mag, habe ich Kalag umgespeckt auf Paladin.
Passt auch ganz gut zu ihrer Story.
Und ich bin ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, was ich spielen soll.
Also, ich habe den kompletten ersten Akt mit Liaselle gespielt.
Und habe dann irgendwann gedacht, okay, probierst du mal was anderes aus.
Ich habe Kalag umgespeckt auf Paladin.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, was mir besser gefällt.
Also, vom Charakter her ist Kalag viel angenehmer als Liaselle.
Liaselle ist nervig.
Ich sage nur, tschück, tschück.
In jedem zweiten Satz.
Und ich weiß halt nicht, was besser ist insgesamt so für das Game.
Ich bin da ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ich meine, Pala hat eindeutig den besseren Damage, wenn sie trifft.
Und mit die besten Support-Fähigkeiten.
Ja, und ein bisschen Heal und sowas nebenbei.
Dafür hat Liaselle als Fighter, gerade mit doppeltem Misty Step,
dass du bist ja mobil ohne Ende.
Und dementsprechend bist du auch schneller ein Gegner dran.
Und du triffst besser.
Was wahrscheinlich unter dem Strich sogar mehr Damage als mit dem Pala bedeutet.
Also wahrscheinlich nimmt es sich nicht allzu viel.
Pala hat halt mega geile Support-Fähigkeiten.
Also, wenn nicht eine der besten im Game.
Und zwar damit, dass eines der besten Fähigkeiten,
Es sei denn, es ist verbuggt in Baldur's Gate 3.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist eigentlich eines der besten Fähigkeiten, die es gibt.
So, also Schmied, was gibt's?
Ne, meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Wir sind falsch.
Daneben müssen wir hin.
Was ist das für ein Übel?
Baldur's Gate 3?
Das hat aber wenig mit Baldur's Gate 1 und 2 zu tun.
Bis jetzt, allerdings, ich habe so die Vermutung,
Leute, spoilert mich nicht und ich spoilere euch auch nicht,
weil ich, keine Ahnung, aber ich habe eine Vermutung,
wenn ich mir so die Story, wie sich die so langsam entwickelt, angucke,
ich könnte mir durchaus noch vorstellen,
dass es die ein oder anderen Bezüge zu Baldur's Gate 2 geben wird.
Also ein paar Charaktere aus Baldur's Gate 2,
oder was heißt ein paar, ein Charakter bisher,
aus Baldur's Gate 1 und 2 ist übrigens auch schon wieder aufgetaucht,
nämlich die hier.
Die gab's schon in Baldur's Gate 1 und in Baldur's Gate 2 konnte man sie romancen,
habe ich aber nie gemacht.
Ansonsten ist wenig Bezug zu 1 und 2 da.
Okay, let's go.
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Könnte ein bisschen leise sein, ne?
Ich glaube, die reden ein bisschen zu.
Gute und schlechte Kunde.
Komm, komm, wir sind nett zu Kalak.
Lauter.
Ich mach ein Stückchen.
Ich muss ja gucken, dass die Spells jetzt nicht so laut sind.
Let's go, Infernal Iron einsammeln.
Okay, wo müssen wir hin?
Beim Händler waren wir schon hier runter, hier runter, da müssen wir hin.
Okay, das ist natürlich praktisch.
Hier müssen wir hin für die Sidequest und hier müssen wir hin für die Companion Quest.
Ja, das ist gut, das machen wir doch.
Auf geht's.
Hopp hopp.
Habe ich noch eine Rast übrig?
Oh, habe ich nicht.
Aber ich glaube, ich sollte noch genug Spells und alles haben.
Übrigens auch so ein Ding, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit Baldur's Gate 1 und 2,
wo man merkt, dass es halt schon ein bisschen viel Divinity Original Sinn mit drin hat,
ist dieses Charaktersystem hier mit diesen Ketten und sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was an dem klassischen Baldur's Gate System verkehrt war,
wo man einen Kreis um seine Party gezogen hat oder anklicken konnte, wen man steuern will.
Vollkommen easy, jeder hat es verstanden, alle konnten es und hier passiert es dir so oft,
dass dir deine Charakter irgendwo hinrennen, wo du nicht hinrennen willst,
dass du irgendwie in den Fight kommst und die anderen den Fight nicht richtig treuen.
Also, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich sage, ja, es funktioniert,
ich verstehe aber nicht, was der Vorteil davon ist.
Äh, glaube ich überhaupt richtig?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ich bin, oder?
Ich glaube schon, dass ich richtig bin.
Äh, ich muss nach Süden runter.
Süden.
Okay, nice.
Und was auch mega nice wäre, wenn man auf die Minimap klicken könnte zum Navigieren.
Und so verliert man manchmal ein bisschen den Überblick.
So, hier ist alles dead, gell?
Oh, ich muss meinen.
Ich habe das Game nur für euch wieder auf Deutsch gestellt, ne?
Also die Texte, die Sprachausgabe bleibt ja Englisch.
Ich glaube, es gibt gar keine andere außer die englische Sprachausgabe.
Oh, wie kommen wir denn hier rüber?
Easy, Level Up.
Ne, gleich, gleich Level Up.
Bin immer viel.
265 EXP.
Nice.
Bin ich richtig?
Ja.
Okay.
Dein Metzgilde.
Okay, die Musik hat gechanged.
Das heißt, es passiert irgendwas.
Noch ein zweites Pet.
Ich habe, glaube ich, schon 60 oder 70 Stunden oder so.
Also ich habe wirklich alles abgesucht in Akt 1.
Und auch bis jetzt in Akt 2.
Ich habe alles, was das Game hergegeben hat.
Die Mauer sieht so aus, als könnte man die kaputt machen.
Kann man nicht.
So, wir stelzen mal.
So, jetzt mal stelzen.
Und bester, bester Erkundungsstelzer ist mein Pet.
Pet kann sich nicht mehr unsichtbar machen.
Äh, nein, nein, nein, Pet, du sollst da unten durch.
Und jetzt kann man das Pet einfach mal erkunden lassen.
Das ist fast schon OP.
Guck, das Pet kann sogar hochfliegen und so.
Das kannst du nicht abschütteln.
Kommt überall hin.
Hier sind überhaupt keine Gegner.
Ich hätte gedacht, hier ist alles voll.
Aber erst mal ein bisschen auskundschaften.
Hier ist ja gar nichts.
Oder es ist wieder so ein Ding, dass man erst mit seinen NPCs, äh, mit seinen Charaktern hinlaufen muss, das was spawnt.
Das macht das Game ganz gerne.
So nach dem Motto, wie, du willst im Vorfeld erkunden?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das gibt's nicht.
Wir spawnen random, wenn du hier langläufst.
Ey, dann hätte ich mir das Ganze auch sparen können.
Off.
Dann müssen wir auch nicht hier rumschleichen.
Wo war die Truhe?
Zept.
Aha, aha, was ist hier los?
Der Obermetzwer.
Ich habe ja ein bisschen so meine Bedenken.
Dass, dass die gleich fünf...
Fücher um mich drumherum spawnen.
Erstmal alles grabben.
Ach ja, und...
Ich meine den Streamtitel ernst.
Das Game ist zu einfach.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch auch spielt.
Und auch den Eindruck hat.
Hm.
Sollte ich mal aufs Dach gucken?
Kann man aufs Dach?
Ah.
Lass es doch mal gucken.
Was hier so abgeht auf dem Dach.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich spiele das schon auf...
Auf dem schwierigsten...
Das Game ist wirklich nicht schwer.
Oh, eine Truhe.
Mit nichts drin.
Das Game hat unglaublich viele Kisten und Loot.
Aber das meiste kannst du eigentlich gar nicht gebrauchen.
Äh, wo bin ich? Hier.
Hallo, stehen...
Jungs, wo rennt ihr hin? Bleibt da!
Hier ist überhaupt nichts, ne?
Ah, Moment.
Hier geht es irgendwo rein.
Holzluke? Wo? Wie? Was?
Wo habe ich was übersehen?
Da unten?
Ach, da! Alter, wer soll das denn sehen?
Da musst du erstmal drauf kommen, dass da hinten in der Ecke was ist.
Ah, okay, wir sehen ein bisschen schön geklitscht.
Ein bisschen Gegner durch die Wand. Nice.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Die da hinten dürfen wir nicht anklicken. Den dürfen wir anklicken. Okay.
Gehen wir erstmal in den Keller gucken, was da abgeht.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen.
Habe ich alle meine Spells ab?
Mage-Armor am Start.
Ja, sieht gut aus.
Ohne Mage-Armor ist Gale 2-Shot von allem.
Hatten die nicht so eine Statistik gepostet?
Welche Charakter am meisten gespielt werden?
Ich glaube...
Also, ich glaube, Shadowheart hat irgendwie jeder in der Party.
Ah, was ist das?
Steinwappen mit Schlüssel doch.
Das kann man doch bestimmt knacken.
Muss man doch bestimmt keinen Schlüssel suchen.
Gale ist der beste Schlossknacker hier.
Weil...
Gale hat so eine Rüstung an bei mir mit...
Plus auf Dex und Advantage auf Schlossknackwürfe.
Wobei 18 ist halt ganz schön hoch.
So, mal gucken.
Wir können das durchaus schaffen.
Es gibt Plus 4 von Dex obendrauf.
Es gibt Advantage.
Also, wir müssen halt irgendwie...
15 oder so müssen wir halt mindestens mal...
13 oder so müssen wir halt...
Dankeschön, Sebasu-chan, für den Sub.
Wir müssen halt würfeln. Mal gucken, ob das klappt.
Und, und...
Alter, was ist das?
So nett.
Okay, aber wir haben ja zum Glück genug Dietriche am Start.
What the...
Alter, du hast Advantage, Gale.
Jetzt stell dich mal nicht so an.
Es ist zwar 18, aber ich habe Advantage plus ordentlich Plus.
Das sollte durchaus machbar sein.
Ja, geht doch.
Sollte durchaus machbar sein.
Guck, 26. Zack, easy. Weiter.
So, habe ich hier noch irgendwas...
Ein Aufzug ist hier.
Aufzug ist für...
Ach nee.
Das ist ein Aufzug, was mir einfach als Questmarke anzeigt.
Übrigens, mein Pet.
Komm mal her.
Das Steinwirt will uns was sagen.
Nice.
Eure Reise endet hier. Aha.
Ja, da ist ja nicht der Erste, der das sagt.
Der wird jetzt easy gebasht.
Ich habe so einen Reflex.
Ich will in alles reingucken, was in dem Game...
Was auch schon in Divinity übelst bescheuert gewesen ist.
In so einem Larian-Game in alles reinzugucken...
Oh, hey.
Keck, wait.
Ähm...
Wait a minute.
Kann ich rausspringen? Nein.
Kann ich raus Misty-Steppen? Ja.
Die Frage ist nur, sollte ich raus Misty-Steppen?
Kann Gale...
Okay, kann Gale das hier knacken? Nein.
Okay, will.
Nee, wir...
Okay, wir machen das so.
Ich probiere, das Ding zu entschärfen.
Will ist zwar nicht der beste Entschärfer,
aber immerhin, Will hat 18 Decks mittlerweile.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Okay, komm.
10, 10, easy, easy.
Guck mal.
Wir haben 5 bis 8 Bonus.
Das heißt, wir müssen mindestens nur 5 würfeln.
Das sollte doch machbar sein, oder?
Geht trotzdem noch, geht trotzdem noch.
Shit.
Alter, okay.
Ich will dafür eigentlich nicht meine Inspiration raushauen.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Machen wir hier noch dabei.
So, wir kriegen jetzt 6 bis 18 Pluspunkte.
Wir müssen eigentlich schon eine 1 würfeln,
dass das jetzt nichts wird.
Naja, nicht wirklich, aber...
Komm.
Ja, easy, 17.
Pass auf, jetzt kriegen wir 50, oder ey.
Guck mal, der Würfel kann gar nicht mehr zählen,
das haben wir jetzt gekriegt.
Nice.
So, und das Schöne ist...
Oh, sind da drüben auch noch welche.
Das Schöne ist, jetzt sind wir ja safe, vermute ich.
Ja, easy, guck, jetzt sind wir safe.
Nice.
Ja, jetzt kann Will so viele Fehlschläge haben, wie er will.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Ja, jetzt kriegt er natürlich keine Fehlschläge mehr.
Wisst ihr, jetzt easy.
Aber erst mal...
Oh.
Aber erst mal meine ganze Inspiration verballern, ist klar.
So, entschärfen, das macht Gale.
Das macht er, wie er will, genau.
Entschärfen.
So, oh, 18.
Ich meine, wir haben Advantage.
Plus...
Come on, break it up, easy.
Einfach...
Beste.
Ich hoffe, es macht noch irgendeiner so einen Baldur's Gate 3 Transmog-Mod,
weil die Rüstung ist übertrieben pog für Gale,
weil plus zwei Decks und Advantage bei Geschicklichkeitswürfen
ist halt mega nice.
Leider sieht die Rüstung halt total hängengeblieben aus.
Wait a minute, hatte ich mit Will nicht noch Schuhe an?
Äh, mit Gale?
Wie komme ich auf Will?
Moment, Gale, du hattest doch mal...
Moment, Gale, du hattest doch mal magische Schuhe an.
Wo sind denn die hin?
Die habe ich wahrscheinlich aus Versehen mal ins Lager geschmissen.
Will, hast du noch irgendwas dabei, was Gale,
irgendwelche Schlappen, die Gale anziehen kann?
Nee.
Na gut, müssen wir ins Lager gucken, ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich essentiell.
Gale owned auch so.
Wait a minute, war da nichts drin, oder habe ich das schon gelootet?
Chat, brain lag.
War da nichts drin, oder habe ich das schon gelootet?
Lucy live, danke für den Host.
Habe ich das schon gelootet?
Chat, brain lag.
Boomerhirn.
War da nichts drin?
Das war irgendwie eine Chip8-Kiste, oder?
Da war überhaupt nichts drin?
Riesenakt?
Riesenakt ranzukommen und dann ist da nichts.
Was soll denn das?
Ey, wenn das hier schon zu viel ist,
du willst nicht wissen, wie die Kiste in meinem Lager aussieht.
Aber ich muss ja auch hier den Schrott einsammeln.
So.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Spell Slots aus?
Gale hat fast alles noch und Shadowheart hat auch noch fast alles.
Top.
Schleichen wir da mal rein.
Patrick, das Schlimme ist ja,
es gibt ja tatsächlich sowas für das Game, ne?
Übrigens, wisst ihr,
ich glaube der aktuelle Weltrekord,
Baldur's Gate 3, ist glaube ich bei 8 Minuten oder sowas.
Schaut mal, Speedrun.
Ach du Kacke.
Okay, no Gale, sollten wir machen.
Ja, 49 Minuten.
Weil Gale ist easy,
mit Gale gibt es eine Abkürzung zum,
in Anführungsstrichen, Durchspielen.
Wobei das halt ein Game ist.
Wenn du die Hälfte vom Game skippst,
hast du halt nichts von.
Aber mit Gale gibt es halt eine Abkürzung.
Weil Gale kann halt explodieren.
Und wenn er an der passenden Stelle explodiert,
dann,
dann gibt es halt Abspann.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Irgendwelche,
was auch immer das sein soll.
Irgendwelche Blobs.
Schatten, Schatten.
Okay.
So, Fivehead, Fivehead.
Also,
wir CC'n erstmal die Hälfte.
Oh, nice.
Die kriegt man ja fast alle.
So,
ich save-scamme relativ wenig.
Aber,
leider,
hat das Game keine richtige Anzeige,
von wo man Sichtlinie hat.
Und,
also ich kann jetzt beispielsweise nicht sagen,
guck mal hier,
ich habe jetzt Sichtlinie dahin,
und von hier die Sichtlinie dahin.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Deswegen, die einzigen Sachen, wo ich save-scamme ist,
weil es mir ohne Eifer mehr Spaß macht,
ist,
zu sehen, wo das Game anzeigt.
Also, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hierhin klicke,
und es wird angezeigt,
alle vier Gegner sind im Radius,
und die Hälfte ist nicht im Radius,
was in dem Game durchaus vorkommen kann,
dann reloade ich, weil das ist halt eindeutig ein Bug.
So, Will,
gib ihm.
Hüpf nur.
Okay, zwei haben,
zwei haben Rhythm.
Wait a minute.
Will,
was ist hier los?
Alter, guck,
das meine ich,
das buggt manchmal übelst rum, das Game.
Das hat jetzt keinen Fight initiiert,
und die sind nicht mal hypnotisiert.
Und das ist halt, das ist halt Kacke.
Deswegen,
das ist der einzige Fall, wo ich save-scamme,
weil,
das ist halt ewig kaputt.
Normalerweise würde man erwarten,
man castet einen CC-Spell auf die Gegner,
und der Fight geht los,
aber der Fight ging nicht los.
Okay,
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt gleich nochmal machen.
Und alle anderen sollen mit.
Wie weit bist du schon?
Ich hab, ich hab nur einmal bisher gestreamt.
Ich bin ungefähr so,
sagen wir mal,
Hälfte, Akt 2.
Also ich bin, würde ich sagen,
so ungefähr
halb durch das Game.
Okay, jetzt hat's, jetzt hat's halbwegs funktioniert.
Oh oh, Will, Will, Will.
Oh nice, guck mal,
diesmal sind sogar alle CC-ed.
Easy.
Okay, wir gehen,
nee, Will, du bleibst da stehen.
Was haben wir hier oben?
Hier oben haben wir einen Schatten.
Will kann eh nicht angreifen.
Will, du bleibst hier erstmal stehen.
Gail,
macht mal Damage auf den hier oben.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob Gail den gescheit sieht.
Ah, doch, Gail sieht den.
Bei denen, die hier oben sind,
Gail sieht den.
Bei denen Viechern kann ich mir immer nicht merken,
ob die feuerresistent sind oder so.
Feuerresistent sind,
Feuerschein aus magischen Angriffen gegen diese Kreaturen.
Nein, das ist natürlich Kacke.
Okay, aber nachdem die Hälfte CC-ed ist,
sollte das relativ easy sein.
Die sind noch eine Runde hypnotisiert.
Warum eine?
Die sollten zwei Runden sein.
Wie soll ich eigentlich,
wie soll ich eigentlich easy gewinnen?
Ja, komm, wenn mir sonst nichts einfällt,
Magic Missile.
Ich bleib mal hier hinten stehen.
Aber Will verpisst sich.
Das Ding hier ist unsichtbar.
So, das darf jetzt hochfliegen
und nochmal Damage machen.
Patrick, hast du das Game auch?
Also ich kann es echt empfehlen,
auch wenn es...
Hä?
Ach, der war nicht im Kampf, weil er unsichtbar war.
Auch wenn es nicht wirklich
ein Baldur's Gate 3 ist,
in dem Sinne von Baldur's Gate 1 und 2,
ist es trotzdem ein richtig gutes Game geworden.
Ja, die Sache ist halt die,
warum wurde der Kampf nicht initiiert
instant, als ich gecastet habe.
Ich meine, ich habe hier auf die...
Ich habe hier...
Normalerweise startet der Kampf ja direkt,
sobald du Spells castest auf die Gegner.
Das ist teilweise ein bisschen weird.
Au!
Wo ist das Vieh hin?
Okay, Kala, auf geht's.
Ja, gut.
Dann würde ich sagen,
gib es jetzt aufs Maul.
Und zwar kommst du da so hin?
Kommst du da mit Jump hin?
Ich hoffe mal.
Okay, gut.
So, 80%.
So, Bonus Action ist weg durch das Springen.
Oh, ich habe keine Zauber...
Warte mal, ich habe keine Slots mehr.
Jetzt mache ich ja kaum Damage mit meinem Palla.
Okay, nach dem Fight muss ich eh rasten.
Bam!
Betäuben, betäuben ist nie verkehrt.
Nice.
Macht das Ding schon mal nix nächsten Zug?
Ich hoffe, dass
Stun
regelkonform wirkt.
Wenn ja, sollte ich eigentlich hier rauslaufen dürfen?
Ja, darf ich.
So, Kratzer
hier vorne hin.
Ja, betäubt, sehr schön.
So, Shadowheart.
Die macht jetzt das, was sie am besten kann.
Spirit Guardians an.
Und ich hoffe, das passt vom Abstand her.
Da rein porten.
Damage gemacht.
Au!
Okay, den machen wir jetzt platt.
Will sieht ihr nicht?
Wisst ihr, was mega nice wäre
in dem Game, wenn man eine Sichtlinienanzeige hätte?
Weil ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man
ob, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich den von hier aus sehe.
Meint ihr, man sieht den von hier?
Man weiß es halt nicht.
Ich hoffe mal.
Ich meine, wir können auf Nummer sicher gehen und
ich weiß es halt nicht.
Ich hoffe, man sieht ihn.
Ja.
Okay, dead.
So, wir sollten danach Level up haben, habe ich.
Chatge, Frage, was gibt's hier?
Dockerfrage an den HighIQ-Chat.
Warum nutzt man Docker-Config bei Swarm?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe Swarm schon noch nie verwendet.
Wenn man die jeweilige Config-File...
Moment, was?
Wenn man die jeweilige Config-File sowieso schon per Copy-Befehl
im Docker-File rüber kopiert,
welchen Zweck hat Docker-Config?
Ist das einfach nur eine Möglichkeit,
seine Config-Files zu verwalten?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne mich
mit Swarm
nicht aus.
Keine Ahnung.
Chatge, vielleicht weiß es jemand von euch.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, ich hoffe, Will kriegt jetzt nicht da oben
von denen auf den Sack gleich.
Welche Klasse spielst du am liebsten?
Normalerweise Sorcerer,
aber
also bei fast allen Games spiele ich als erstes
bei allen, die...
Pathfinder und Dungeons & Dragons
basierten Games
spiele ich eigentlich für das erste Playthrough
immer Sorcerer.
Allerdings
in Malos G3 nicht, weil
man nur 4
Party-Slots hat.
Das heißt,
war ein neues Video, ich habe gestern aufgenommen.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das
die Woche hochlade oder vielleicht sogar
dann lieber Ende der Woche.
Nachdem man eh mindestens einen Cleric
und einen Wizard im Team braucht
und man maximal Story mitbekommen will,
habe ich Gale genommen als
Hauptcharakter
und keinen eigenen erstellt.
Weil ansonsten ist es halt ein bisschen blöd,
die 2 sind eh fest.
Ohne Shadowhunt und Gale kannst du eigentlich
nicht richtig spielen.
So, dann brauchst du noch einen Tank
und dann hast du als letzten Slot eigentlich
nur noch Will offen.
Astarion juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe die Astarion-Quest
noch nicht mal in Akt 1 angefangen.
Wahrscheinlich ist die jetzt auch verfallen
und kein Bock.
Okay, Gale, weißt du was?
Du gibst Kalak jetzt einfach mal
Haste.
Und wenn du Glück hast, kommst du
kommst du nicht vielleicht bei Shadowhunt
noch in den
in den Kreis.
Egal, komm.
So, du gibst dir mit.
Du gibst Kalak Haste
und dann hoffst du,
dass die von dir wegbleiben,
weil du in den Spirit Guardians stehst.
Obwohl 19 AC ganz gut geschützt bist eigentlich.
Dafür sind die jetzt scharf auf Will.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Will, du musst da weg.
So, Kalak wird die jetzt
richtig krass destroyen,
weil die hat Haste
und er ist gestunt.
Der kriegt den so auf den Sack.
Bam, next.
Der hat ge...
Ja, das war's.
Mehr Angriff habe ich nicht.
Muss er was heilen?
Nope.
Oh, Shadowhunt.
Shadowhunt geht Damage machen.
Gut.
Jetzt steht Gale natürlich
ein bisschen blöd da vorne.
Wollen wir?
Ich muss danach eh lange Rast machen.
Also wir können das Ding jetzt
einfach komplett wegblasten.
Nice, Kamera.
GG.
Drei leben noch.
Ja, nice.
Ja, Gale hat glücklicherweise
Mage-Armor
und extrem viel Dex.
Das heißt, wisst ihr was das witzige ist?
Gale hat
fast so viele AC
wie mein Cleric und mein Tech.
Nur Will ist nicht so weit oben.
Er hat nur 17.
Aber deswegen ist Dex
für alle Charakters immer sinnvoll,
weil Dex
die Armor-Class erhöht,
wenn man
keine oder leichte Rüstung trägt.
Bei mittlerer Rüstung ist es
nicht mehr so viel.
Bei schwerer Rüstung gar nicht.
Ja gut, Will, du kannst den jetzt
einfach wegblasten und wir haben gewonnen.
Okay.
Lauf da hin und blaste den weg.
Bam.
Easy.
Und Level.
Wait a minute.
Warum hat Will Level Up
und der Rest nicht?
Wie geht denn das?
Ich dachte, XP ist komplett synchron.
Moment, Will hat auch keine Schuhe an?
Nee, Moment.
Doch, Will hat Schuhe an.
Ja, Will könnte ich aber auch mal
ordentliche Schuhe anziehen.
Warum ist die XP nicht synchron?
Das ist mir neu.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Ich dachte, dass alles
komplett synchron ist.
Okay, entschärfen.
Gail, tu dein Bestes.
Bonus, jawohl.
Au, 21.
Gail,
gib dir Mühe.
Jawohl, easy.
Fast schon Gambling-Stream.
Gambling-Stream.
Geht es rein in die Slots?
Rich, Alter.
So, und jetzt noch Schlossknappen.
Da muss ja was Gutes drin sein.
Wenn das
eine Falle dran hat
und abgeschlossen ist.
Okay.
Was ist drin?
Ein Helm.
Helm der Arkanen Sinnesschärfe.
Wenn du bei einem Waffenangriff
Schaden bewirkst, erhältst du
zwei zusätzlichen ...
What?
Das ist auch so ein Baldur's Gate eigenes Ding.
Die betroffene Kreatur hat einen Bonus
von plus eins auf ihre
Kreatur und auf den
Zauberschwierigkeitsgrad
pro verbleibendem Zug.
What?
Jetzt weiß ich, was die meinen.
Äh, Spell Safe, meinen die.
Okay, ähm.
Taugt das was?
Wenn du bei einem Waffenangriff Schaden ...
Ja, ja ...
Das bringt mir ja nicht wirklich was,
weil
ich mache ja mit keinem
meiner Caster
so wirklich
Waffenangriffe.
Das wäre vielleicht für Will ganz cool,
wenn ich den auf Nahkampf specken würde,
aber ansonsten ...
Ansonsten eigentlich ...
Irgendwie habe ich Gale ein bisschen verkackt,
und zwar,
der hat keinen Helm an,
der hat keinen Umhang an,
der hat keine Schuhe mehr an.
Also irgendwas habe ich mit ihm
zu tun.
Was, was ...
Wir gehen jetzt eh ins Lager,
da müssen wir uns mal schnell
einen Helm und noch ein paar Schuhe
für Gale suchen.
Aber vorher hoffe ich,
dass ich irgendwie noch 100 XP
bekomme.
Einmal hier irgendwas zum ...
Lass mich nochmal runter,
ich will nochmal runter,
runter, runter, runter.
Ich will nochmal hier Silber,
Silberkram looten.
Was zum Teufel?
Steinmetz-Protokoll
hat einfach XP gegeben.
Jetzt haben alle Level-Up außer Gale.
Alter, was ist mit dir los, Gale?
Fünf XP!
Fünf XP, man.
Bisher hatte ich nur
synchrone Level-Aufstiege,
wie geht das überhaupt,
dass die nicht synchron ...
Kann das sein,
dass die Personal Quests ...
Vielleicht geben die
persönlichen Quests
XP nur für den Charakter
und ich habe mit Gale seine Quests
noch nicht weit genug gemacht,
dass der was kriegt?
Komisch, auf jeden Fall.
Aber Level-Up gibt es erst,
wenn alle Level-Up haben.
Fünf XP, ich meine,
ich muss bei irgendeinem Gegner anhusten,
dann ...
habe ich fünf XP.
Habe ich alles schon ...
Vielleicht gibt das XP.
No Pass.
Ah!
Ein Knopf!
Guckt mal da!
Wer hat es erkannt?
Shadowheart!
Die anderen haben es alle verkackt.
Aber gut, Shadowheart hat auch hohes Wisdom.
Die erkennt sowas.
Sinnlose Klamotten einsammeln.
Hier muss alles gelootet werden.
Alles wird gelootet.
Yeah.
Das heißt nur,
dass man die Bücher verkaufen geht gleich.
Okay, was haben wir hier drin?
Okay, wenn das jetzt irgendeine
Mimik-Truhe ist oder so,
dann habe ich reingeschissen,
weil ich habe ...
Ich habe fast nichts mehr an Slots
und auch keine Short-Rest mehr.
Guck mal.
Hier gibt es ...
Hier gibt es schon mal einen Hebel.
Der macht wahrscheinlich einfach nur die Tür auf und zu.
Ja.
Ah!
Das ist nice.
Das habe ich gesucht die ganze Zeit.
Knock ist ein Spell zum Schlösser knacken.
Das haben die eigentlich ganz clever gemacht,
dass wenn man kein Rogue dabei hat,
dass man trotzdem ...
Oder wenn man keinen Charakter dabei hat,
der gut Schlösser knacken kann
und trotzdem mal ein Schloss knacken,
dass Wizards das auch machen können.
Wobei man halt sagen muss ...
Man kann sagen, das kann er doch schon alles.
Moment, habe ich das schon?
Ah, ich habe das sogar schon.
Okay, dann habe ich nichts gesagt.
So.
Weinregal plündern.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist er auch noch überladen.
Das kriegt Karlag mal.
Das braucht die eh.
Plattenpanzer ins Lager.
Ich muss unbedingt mal
hier ist
zu viel
Zeit.
Guck mal, was ich hier alles für ein Mist drin habe.
Okay, schwere Truhe.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Trank der Unsichtbarkeit, Trank der Geschwindigkeit.
Okay, alles ganz praktisch.
So ein paar Schuhe für ...
Ein Helm und ein paar Schuhe für Gale wäre ein Pog.
Okay, nice.
Haben wir es geschafft.
Raus hier.
Irgendwas vergessen?
Nö, nö, alles
geschafft.
So 5 XP wären halt noch extrem Poggers.
Wait a minute.
Hier geht eine Leiter rauf und hier geht ein
Aufzug rauf.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wofür der Aufzug ...
Moment, man kann hier hochklettern
und man kann in den Aufzug.
Die Frage ist nur, wie ...
Hm.
Wie kommt man in den Aufzug rein?
Okay, testen wir mal was.
Da muss man speichern, nicht dass ich ...
Ah ne, geht nicht.
Hm.
Wenn ich das Gewicht kaputt mache,
ist wahrscheinlich keine allzu schlaue Idee.
Hä?
Man kann einfach draufklicken und easy.
Es funktioniert.
Da ist was.
Okay, bevor wir was machen,
müssen wir ins Lager und pennen.
So, erstmal ...
Allerwichtigste Tätigkeit jedes Mal,
wenn man ins Lager geht.
Erstmal eine Runde die Katze streicheln.
Gut.
Pflicht erfüllt.
Will irgendeiner reden?
Ne.
Keiner.
Keiner hat Bock zu schwätzen.
Gut.
Dann ...
Gucken wir nochmal in die Truhe rein,
ob da irgendwas dabei ist,
was Gale aufziehen kann.
Und Will ...
Ja.
Darf man ein bisschen sein Inventar leer räumen.
So.
Wir machen jetzt hier mal ...
Also was brauchen wir für Geld?
Wir brauchen einen Helm, wir brauchen einen Umhang,
wir brauchen Schuhe.
Okay, let's go.
Ups, nein, ich will noch kein Level ...
Nein, wir machen Level Up mit allen zusammen.
So, hiervon brauche ich, ehrlich gesagt,
gar nichts,
außer die Wiederbelebungsschrift rollen,
ans Lager senden.
Hm.
Keiner braucht
eigentlich
auch nichts hiervon,
außer den Trank.
Die Wiederbelebungsrollen, das ist okay,
den Schlüsselbund darfst du auch behalten.
Heiltrank und die Münzen
an Lager senden.
Gale,
was du da für Zeug ...
Gale, du brauchst hiervon doch auch nichts.
Du brauchst das Buch,
du brauchst die Heiltränke,
du brauchst Entschärfungszeug,
den Ball,
Gold kannst du mal behalten.
Und sonst,
und sonst,
das kannst du auch da lassen.
Die Scrolls können wir auch im ...
Okay, der Rest kann eigentlich ans Lager.
Sehr gut, so, und Will,
Will ist halt total überladen, so.
Also, guck mal hier.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das ist doch ein schöner Helm für,
für Gale, oder?
Wenn dir ein Rettungswurf gelingt,
erleidet der Gegner,
der diesen Wurf verursacht hat,
1 bis 4 Psychenschaden.
Ne, das ist Mist für Gale.
So, mal kurz ein paar Typen sortieren.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Wenn du einen Zustand bewirkst,
erhältst du 2 Runden.
Meine Güte, was zum ...
Ach, Waffenangriffe,
ja, das bringt mir nichts.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Geheimerkritische Treffer ist auch für ...
Besser.
Jägersmann.
Ich muss, ich muss mal zu einem Händler mit Will.
Das wird so nix.
Das wird, das wird so nix.
Okay, Gale, was kriegst du?
Du brauchst, du brauchst einen Helm
und du brauchst ein paar Schuhe.
Typ.
Oh, was haben wir denn da?
Schrift, das kann ich alles verkaufen, ne?
Ich hab bis jetzt bloß noch keinen Bock.
So, also.
Gale, Helm, was haben wir hier?
Kappe, das brauchen wir nicht.
Kappe der Heilung brauchen wir auch nicht.
Helm, das ...
Auch nix für Gale.
Was?
Kreatur in einem Angriff gegen den Träger scheitert.
Auch nix für Gale.
Helm der Sinnesschärfe, wenn du ...
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Kaputte ...
Ja, mittlere Rüstung ist für Gale auch nix.
Das ist auch nix.
Ja, ich hab keinen ...
Ich glaub, ich hab schlicht und ergreifend
nix Gescheites für Gale.
Als Helm.
Deswegen hat der auch nix auf.
So, hab ich ein paar Schuhe.
Ich hab ein paar sinnvolle Schuhe.
Mittlere Rüstung bringt mir auch nix.
Spur ...
Pederfaden.
Naja.
Okay, das ist für Gale gar nicht mal so übel.
Wenn er ein bisschen schlecht ist,
weil er nicht schneller rennen kann.
Wenn du ein Zauber wirkst,
der Konzentration erfordert,
hältst du 1 Hut lang Wut.
So was Unsinniges.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, dann kriegt das hier ...
Kriegt er das hier halt.
Okay, immerhin.
Wollen wir das 3 Stunden suchen.
Nice Hut.
Okay, fuck.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal mit ...
Ach, scheiß drauf, wir gehen nicht zum Händler.
Ich pack das jetzt alles in ...
Ich mein, Will braucht nix davon hier.
Will braucht die ...
Laterne.
Die Laterne.
So, die Scrolls kann er behalten.
Und die Schaufel.
Fertig.
Die Glocke brauche und ...
Das war's.
Hoffe ich mal.
Ach ja, und ...
Und das Gold, falls er welches hat,
kann er behalten, ja.
Ich kann aus irgendwelchen ...
Oh, dieses Inventarsystem, Mann.
Die ...
Alter.
Wo ist die Glocke?
Die muss ich behalten.
Ich seh sie nicht.
Wo ist sie denn hin?
So, Geld behalten.
Das Artefakt behalten.
Jetzt hat ...
Jetzt hat's wieder anselected.
Alter, das Inventarsystem von dem Game macht mich verrückt, Alter.
Okay, das ist jetzt anders hier.
Zack.
Wo ist die Glocke?
Hier, das ist die Glocke.
Laterne behalten, Glocke behalten.
Und wo ist das Artefakt?
Wie mich das Inventarsystem fertig macht.
Alter, will mich das Game verarschen?
Okay.
Unsichtbar kann man auch mal behalten.
Das braucht keiner hier.
Jetzt hab ich mein ganzes Gold auch in die Truhe gepackt.
Na, meinetwegen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Nice.
So, jetzt kann Will das Gold hier wieder rausholen.
Und wir sind ready.
Weiter geht's.
Gehen wir pennen.
Du hast genügend Lagervorräte, yep.
So, keiner will reden.
Perfekt, dann geht's weiter.
Oh, Storytime.
Will, was geht ab?
Stromplan, Will, beim Tanzen.
Gute Technik.
Habt ihr so tanzen gerne?
Als würde man eine gestalten.
Komm, wir sind nett zu Will.
Ich habe meine Fancyballs und Masquerades besucht.
Ein paar elegante Bewegungen können die richtigen Köpfe umdrehen.
Ich dachte, es sei Zeit, meine Fähigkeiten zu verkleinern.
Ich würde nicht meinen neuen Partner verfehlen.
Wie Glück es hätte.
Er hat nur...
...getanzen.
Ich bin nicht interessiert, Will.
Keine Sorge.
Es geht nicht wirklich ums Tanzen.
Es geht darum, mit wem wir tanzen.
Da steht...
Wobei, ich würde es ungefähr genauso machen.
Ich würde auch einfach nur sinnlos rumstehen und gucken.
Akrobatik, nein, da ist...
Moment!
Akrobatik ist Gale mittlerweile ziemlich gut.
Ich habe plus vier Decks.
Und Advantage auf Deckswürfel.
Dann ist wahrscheinlich Akrobatik für mich noch das Beste an der Stelle jetzt.
Ja, und zehn sollte ich eigentlich auch packen.
Wenn ich plus vier dann müssen wir schon eigentlich unter sechs würfeln.
Naja, easy.
Let's go, Gale. Zeig, was du kannst.
Das war jetzt... Das war alles?
Das hätte ich auch noch hingekriegt.
Zweimal wackeln mit den Armen.
Nervös lächeln, es war nicht schwer.
Ihr lasst es nur schwer...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Nervös lächeln.
Oh, what?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man Will romanzen kann.
Okay, Will...
Wir müssen es nicht übertreiben.
Das ist zu weit gegangen, ich sollte gehen.
Keine gatchy roll.
Pass auf, Will disapproves kommt jetzt oder sowas.
Natürlich.
Der Sonnenschein lebt nur so lange.
Danke.
Für die Enttäuschung, ich meine...
Das war nicht schlecht.
Tut mir leid.
Ich hätte dir ja wenigstens 5 XP-Punkte geben können, oder?
Angrast haben wir Lager verlassen.
Haben wir den...
Okay, eine Runde Licht casten.
Moment.
Damit habe ich doch schon...
Let's go.
Okay, 5 XP.
Das werden wir doch irgendwo noch auftreiben können.
Hier, Skelett.
Hier waren wir...
Moment, war das das, wo ich gerade drinne war?
Ja, glaube schon.
Das sieht dem so ähnlich aus.
Nee, das ist ein anderes...
Doch, doch, doch, jetzt.
Jetzt erkenne ich es.
In dem Winkel erkenne ich das Haus wieder.
Okay.
Gehen wir mal hier oben lang.
Moment.
Wait a minute.
Angeblich ist hier was für die Quest.
Hier.
Genau, hier ist Quest-Stells.
Hier irgendwo.
Ah!
Da kann man Karnak upgraden.
Nice.
Wir gehen trotzdem...
Ja.
Okay, what?
Bin hier noch mehr?
Nein, nein, nein.
Hier ist keins mehr.
Hier waren wir schon.
Wir gehen jetzt da hoch und holen uns noch 5 XP für Level Up.
So, da hinten waren auf jeden Fall Gegner.
Gibt es den Wegpunkt vielleicht?
Hätten wir einen Wegpunkt gesehen?
Ein Wegpunkt wäre sehr nice.
Dann kommen wir nämlich schneller wieder ins Dorf zurück.
Grabstein.
Wer steht denn da rum?
Ara... Arabella ist da am Start.
Arabella kennen wir noch aus Act 1.
Glaubt ihr, das ist die aus Act 1?
Da musste man Arabella, glaube ich, retten.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich kann mir Namen immer so schlecht, was Games angeht, merken.
Wisst ihr was?
Wenn das bei Kickstarter gewesen wäre,
wäre jetzt auf diesem Friedhof Kickstarter gewesen.
Okay, fragen wir mal, was mit Arabella los ist.
Oh, was ist hier los?
Doch, das ist sie.
Naja, komm.
Das passt nicht zu Will.
Arabella, du solltest bei deinen Eltern sein.
Was machst du hier? Hier ist das Gefälle Hexenmeister.
Hexenmeister.
So starke Magie hat meist ihr ein Preiskind.
Wo hast du sie her?
Nice.
Was machst du hier?
Wie wäre es, wenn du mir deine Kräfte beibringst?
Ich weiß nicht.
Arabella, du solltest bei deinen Eltern sein.
Sind die Eltern nicht in diesem Gasthaus?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ich finde, du kannst dich auf mich verlassen.
Ich denke darüber nach.
Wie viel Gold bekomme ich dafür?
Aber Will ist heldenhaft, was sowas angeht.
Ich finde deine Eltern schon.
Darauf kannst du dich verlassen.
Doch doch, warum nicht?
Natürlich, du kannst in meinem Lager bleiben.
Es gibt da einen Gasthausnamen zum letzten Licht.
Nee, die soll lieber zu mir ins Lager gehen.
Bei dem Gasthaus traue ich nicht.
Du bist der Beste.
Du schickst Mama und Papa da hin.
Ich warte auf dich, Held.
Was wird er jetzt machen?
Er spürt einen Schmerz.
Bevor die Schatten diese Frau nahm,
war das jemand, der in der Kämpfe gestorben ist.
Er spürt einen Matriarchen Fluch.
Sie scheint eine Großmutter zu sein.
Ein Kind, das ihre Eltern verliebt hat.
100.
300.
130.
174.
165.
196.
170.
171.
172.
113.
114.
125.
116.
117.
118.
140.
Also umgesetzt ist, aber es gibt halt kaum bei Level-Ups irgendwas
Zu machen. Also wenn man das mal mit Divinity Origins in zwei vergleicht, ist halt ein riesen Ding. Da kannst du bei jedem Level-Up
sinnvoll Progression machen und hier quasi nur bei jedem vierten.
So, also was nehmen wir denn? Zauber ersetzen, jawoll.
Wir kriegen jetzt
vierte, viertlevel Spells glaube ich, gell? Ja.
Nur so wenig?
Da ist ja nix wirklich dabei, was taugt.
Können wir nehmen, ist ganz gut, gerade gegen
Elementare oder solche Geschichten.
Habe ich auf dem Cleric schon, brauche ich hier eigentlich nicht, aber
das sieht gut aus, ist aber nicht gut.
Das habe ich auf irgendeinem anderen Charakter brauche ich
nicht so oft. Zumindest würde ich für einen Teleport von meiner Gruppe keinen Warlock Spellslot opfern wollen.
Ja, Verwarnung.
So, was haben wir denn hier schönes? Attributsverbesserung bringt mir das was, eine Attributsverbesserung.
Charisma, ja, das wäre sehr nice.
Was hat man sonst noch zu bieten?
Dein Charisma wird um eins erhöht, also quasi um einen Half-Feat.
Allerdings, ich brauche keine, ich brauche keine Täuschung auftreten Würfe.
Wachsam auf Initiative ist immer nice, aber will ich nicht. Stärke oder Geschicklichkeit brauchen wir nicht.
Armbrustexpert, Defensiv, zwei Waffenkämpfer, Gewölbeforscher. Ich glaube das heißt auf Englisch Dungeon Explorer.
Widerstandsfähigkeit,
Elementar.
Deine Zauber ignorieren Resistenzen gegen die gewählte Schadensart. Das ist cool,
allerdings
Eldritch Blast ist glaube ich
Schlag, Crush, Damage.
Und da sind eh kaum welche dagegen resistent.
Eldritch Blast, was macht das für ein Damage-Type?
Steht das da? Force Damage, ist das Force Damage? Nicht Crush.
Force Damage, ja.
Das, da ist eh kaum jemand immun dagegen.
War nicht leicht gerüstet, du bist im Umgang mit leichter Rüstung geübt, bin ich eh schon.
Glückspilz, oh das ist gut.
Du erhältst, das ist eigentlich immer nice. Du erhältst drei Glückspunkte, die du nutzen kannst bei
Angriffsattribut und Rettungswürfel im Vorteil zu sein oder einen Gegner zu zwingen seine Angriffswürfel erneut. Das ist mega nice.
Auch für Survival und so. Ist halt die Frage, ob es besser ist als
20 Charisma.
Also, das wird das letzte Feat sein, was man für das gesamte Game jetzt noch sinnvoll
bekommen werden, weil Feats gibt es außer für Fighter immer nur alle vier Level.
Und
ich bin jetzt Level 8, das Game geht bis Level 12.
Also ich kriege quasi das dritte Feat kurz vor Game Ende. Das ist mein letztes Feat, was ich bekomme im Endeffekt.
Also ist halt die Frage.
Ich glaube, ich nehme einfach 20 Charisma. Castingstat ist eigentlich mal das Beste. Lass uns mal schnell gucken, was sonst noch hier.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall mega nice. Sollte ich noch irgendwo mal nicht wissen, was ich nehmen will, dann das.
Mit Shadowheart brauche ich unbedingt Konzentration.
Bade, Cleric, ne, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Was cool wäre, wenn
wenn es
Gibt es Spell Sniper?
Spell Sniper?
Ja, Moment, aber Spell Sniper macht nicht das, was Spell Sniper normalerweise macht.
Spell Sniper erhöht doch normalerweise die Attack Range, oder?
Ja, you range Spells, ignore half cover und ja gut, das gibt es in Baldur's Gate nicht.
Okay, nee, dann lohnt sich Spell Sniper nicht. Dann wird Charisma
Charisma, Braumern
Ist eigentlich das Beste. Castingstat auf 20. Gail!
Da ist der Hut.
Zauber, Stufe 4.
Feuerwand, why not?
Ist das, ist das safe? Ist das ignore on safe, oder?
Wobei, das ist Konzentration, das brauche ich für Haste schon.
Feuerschild, das könnte als CC ganz brauchbar sein. Verwirrung.
Verwirre eine Gruppe von Kreaturen, sie greifen wahllos an, wandern ziellos umher und springen.
Das ist, könnte ganz, das sieht nur gut aus, ist es aber nicht.
Single target damage und so ziemlich die Hälfte aller Gegner sind resistent, also untote resistent gegen Necrotic Damage.
Also, dann, ja, ich weiß nicht, dann ist es wirklich geiles nix.
Ja, kommt, Verwirrung. Ich meine, ich kann eh alle Spells im Game lernen, kein Problem. So, Talent.
Also, bei Gail wäre es natürlich, Moment, Gail, warum hast du nur 17,
Gail, was ist denn mit dir los?
Warum hast du nur 17 int und nicht 18?
Was ist denn mit dir los?
Plus 3,
Was, Intelligenz 17,
Wait a minute, warum hat Gail,
jetzt bin ich verwirrt,
warum hat,
warum habe ich Belastbar geskillt?
Ist ja komplett unsinnig.
Achso, wegen Plus 1 und,
achso,
auf Dex Proficiency habe ich, glaube ich. Okay, das macht, das macht doch Sinn.
Ich brauche jetzt noch ein Feed, was int gibt.
Int,
was gibt int?
Intelligence, increase your intelligence
Intelligence
Or wisdom score, you have five bonus passive wisdom, das ist, das hätte ich jetzt gespeckt,
aber nein, das ist nicht im Game, geil.
Das wäre tatsächlich ganz nice gewesen.
Ja, wie, es gibt nicht seine Intelligenz zu erhöhen.
Das ist ja Schrott.
Ja, das ist ja richtig, da muss ich,
Ability,
Ja, das war bescheuert.
Okay, dann muss ich Gail respekten, das ist verkackt, habe ich, habe ich verkackt, das muss weg.
Beim ersten Feed,
brauche ich int.
Ja,
ja, das ist mies.
So, und beim zweiten Feed nehme ich,
Ja, das ist, das ist echt blöd.
Okay, muss ich,
muss ich, Gail, Gail muss respekt werden, klar.
Weil, das bringt halt so nix. 19 ist halt, 19 ist halt unsinnig.
Es sei denn, ich finde noch irgendwas, um Intelligenz plus 1 zu erhöhen, aber das ist halt, das ist halt Mist.
Ja, ruhig, Gail muss respekt werden.
So, und Shadowheart braucht unbedingt Warcaster.
Die verliert nämlich laufend Konzentration.
Okay, 18,
13 Stärke, das ist okay, die, die haut eh so gut wie nie Melee drauf.
Okay, also egal, so cool es wäre,
plus zu haben,
in
plus 20 Wisdom wäre nice, aber
wir brauchen, wir brauchen Warcaster.
Advantage on saving throws for concentration checks.
Ja,
das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, das ist einfach nur mega op auf Clerics.
Die Frage ist jetzt nur,
kampferprobter Zauberwirker ist wahrscheinlich Warcaster.
Ähm, wenn sich eine killt, also,
du bist bei Rettungswürfen zur aufrechterhaltenden Konzentration auf einen Zauber im Vorteil, yep.
Das braucht Shadowheart, beste.
So, dann eigentlich müssen wir Gail jetzt respekten, aber ich respekte Gail jetzt nicht, das mache ich einfach mal off-stream, ist langweilig.
Gail jetzt mehr skilled.
So, und die kriegt, wo ist es denn? Waffenmeister? Nee.
Nein, wo ist denn hier?
Meine Güte, ich habe das auf deutsch eingestellt. Sieht irgendjemand
Zweihänder,
Zweihänder, Feet
Bilder, Angreifer, Two Weapon Master, Two Hand Weapon. Ja, Meisterschaftsschwerer, wenn du mit einem, einem
kritischen erzielst, oder einen kritischen erkennst du, ja.
Perfekt.
Sollte ich nicht auch eigentlich noch so eine Bonus-Attack kriegen?
Ah ne, Polar Master macht eine Bonus-Attack. Ah ne, wenn ich was gekillt habe.
Critical Hit or kill a target, dann kann ich einen Bonus-Angriff machen, okay.
Okay, nice. Fertig gespeckt, dann lasst uns mal schnell ins Spellbuch gucken.
Gail, kannst du noch irgendetwas spannendes lernen?
Nein, aber du hast noch einen freien Spell-Slot, da nimm,
was nehmen wir denn jetzt?
Feuerwand.
Ja, den kann man, kann man manchmal besser aimen als
Feuerball.
Allerdings ist auch
Creator Invisibility mega nice.
Nehmen wir das mal so. Und Shadowheart, kriegt die irgendwas spannendes, neues? Nope.
Okay, aus ist, gut ist, next.
Let's go.
Okay, aha.
Ein Ring
eines magischen Ringpaars, der dem Träger erlaubt, den
zauberschützenden Spand von der Kreatur zu halten, die den anderen Ring trägt. Okay, das ist cool, wenn man das zwischen dem Caster und dem Tank
oder sowas macht.
Was steht denn da hinten rum?
Okay, hier sind wir richtig.
Los, knappen. Will, gib alles. Will, nee. Will, lass das mal den Profi machen.
Kommt mal Gail zu, der kann das besser.
Guck hier, Gail, easy, easy win.
Das ist der 20, 20 und 1.
Haha, okay, da hätte ich es ohne Advantage jetzt ziemlich verkackt.
20 und 1, geil. Das musst du auch erstmal hinkriegen.
So, hier kommt jetzt bestimmt irgendein Viech raus.
Videostagebuch, ja, perfekt, nice, nice.
Sarkophag.
Stiefel des Scheines. Diese Stiefel gestalten einmal pro kurzer Rast, Todstellen zu wirken. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man
gebasht wird.
Aber da kann er halt nicht mehr reagieren. Das ist halt auch alles ein bisschen doof.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob man das nicht direkt wieder abbrechen kann.
Da oben stehen so viele Leute rum. Was ist denn da los?
Guck mal hier.
Aber wir gehen erstmal hier oben. Wir gehen erstmal abchecken, was noch sonst so los ist hier.
Was ist hier auf dem Friedhof? Noch mehr Särge.
Eisbissrobe.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Das ist, glaube ich, sonst nur Warlock-owned. Also für Gale ist das vielleicht nicht schlecht.
Gale, was hast du aktuell an? Ach ne, der hat das mit Dex an. Das ist das Beste. Das wird das ganze Game wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ausziehen.
Es sei denn, ich finde noch was mega-nices. Kann man nicht aufmachen.
Hier liegt der beste Schmied in Wraithwin. Unsere Schwerter werden uns niemals als Wahrheit zerkleinern.
In Erinnerung an Largo Crivens, der mit seiner Familie am selben schrecklichen Abend zusammengebracht wurde.
Ich wünsche ihnen, dass ihre Todesstörungen eine Rache sind.
Was geht hier? Hier ist doch bestimmt irgendwas nett. Was bin ich hier sehend? Oh.
Irgendwelche Untoten? Alles klar. Ich glaube, die wollen gebashed werden. Moment, die greifen mich gar nicht an.
Dann reden wir nochmal mit der.
Ach gut, Shadowheart erkennt das.
Warum behandelt ihr eine Leiche? Wie ich sehe, habt ihr medizinische Vorräte. Könnt ihr mir was abgeben?
Die sieht nicht so aus, ehrlich gesagt. Als will ich von der irgendwelche medizinischen Vorräte haben. Warum behandelt ihr eine Leiche?
Der Patient ist tot nach einer Weile. Fingerfertigkeit. Die Leiche leicht anstupsen.
Täuschen? Ja, Will. Du bist Poggers, was Charisma angeht.
Wie ich sehe, schläft der Patient friedlich. Ich denke, eure Arbeit ist getan.
Charisma. Guidance hinzufügen. Okay. Ich meine. Okay, komm auch noch dabei.
Wir kriegen jetzt einen Bonus von 7 bis 19. Also, Will. Please. Präge. Würfel jetzt kein Mist, ja?
Okay, das haben wir.
Ja. Ja. Ich wusste, dass diese Hände mich nicht verletzen würden. Der Patient ist sicher, dass er sich erhöht.
Da es jetzt geklärt ist, könnte ich da ein paar Vorräte kaufen. Moment, man kann handeln mit dem Viech.
Oh, was hat die denn hier am Start? Purpurwurmgift. Gut, bringt mir nichts. Ich habe ja keinen Stelzer am Start. Der Rest ist...
Aber die hat richtig viel Kohle. Ich würde sagen, die sollte ich bashen.
Du musst dich überhaupt nicht um den Patient kümmern. Ich habe dir doch schon gesagt, du kannst gehen.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich Arabellas Vater. Okay. Ich lasse das Viech mal leben. Ballübung. Okay, Leute, wir lassen einfach alles liegen.
Wir lassen alles liegen. Wir krabben nur das, was ein bisschen was wert ist.
Truhe. Oh, Bücher lese ich ja nicht. Ich klicke die nur an, falls es irgendwelche Questsachen gibt.
Truhe. Haben wir hier unten noch irgendwas? Zollhaus? Okay, hier unten geht es dann mit der Mainquest weiter. Da gehen wir nicht hin. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal hier.
Hier rauf. Haus der Heilung. Becke. Okay, das ist die eigentliche Sidequest, die ich machen will. Es wäre cool, wenn ich mal einen Teleporter finden würde.
Wir könnten ein bisschen cheaten und auf die Map gucken, wo es hier einen Teleporter gibt. Das machen wir jetzt auch.
Ich lasse mir aber nichts spoilern von der Map und auch nicht irgendwie helfen. Okay, mein Browser ist kaputt. Oder so? Mein Browser kaputt?
Alter, was zum Teufel geht mit meinem Browser ab? Oder ist die Seite gerade überlastet? Kann es sein? Ich glaube, die Seite ist. Die Seite ist einfach überlastet. Das liegt nicht an meinem Browser.
Bin ich sehend. Die Seite ist kaputt. Das ist natürlich doof. Shadow Cursed Land. Ich will wissen, wo der nächste Teleporter ist. Okay, nice.
Ist das gerade alles am Abkacken hier so ein bisschen? Wo ist ein Teleporter? Hier? Moment, was haben denn Teleporter für Steine und Kringel? Gibt es hier so Kringel? Da! Da gibt es einen Teleporter.
Moment, hier oben gibt es auch einen Teleporter. Hier oben gibt es auch einen Teleporter. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich unterirdisch. Okay, dann gehen wir mal in die Richtung jetzt. Let's go.
Achja, Sekunde. Mage Armor. Also erstmal hier beschwören. Mage Armor. Pet. Was haben wir da hinten? Trank. Tränke kann man immer. Crappen. Ah, das ist eine andere.
Die wird bestimmt böse, wenn ich das aufmache. Okay, pass mal auf. Gucken wir mal, ob wir den NPC gebeten können.
Ha, gebetet. Will lenkt die ab und Gail knackt einfach den Tisch. Easy. Das hat sich aber nicht sonderlich gelohnt. Ich habe keine Zeit. Ich muss den Doktor sofort sehen.
Ich bin der neue Assistent des Doktors. Eine Krankheit vortäuschen. Überzeugen ist Will extrem gut. Ja, überzeugen kann er.
Okay, ich hätte gerne noch Guidance, falls das möglich ist. 16. Warum kriege ich jetzt... Ich würde gerne Guidance casten mit Shadowheart, wenn das erlaubt ist. Hast du schon mal Escape vom Tag auf probiert? Nein. Easy. Ich bin der neue Assistent vom Doktor, Leute.
Die Hand des Doktors wird sie schließen. Nach dem Theater. Sei schnell. Sei gerettet.
Im Flur.
Das sieht ja... Das sieht ja sehr einladend aus. Okay, Will stellst...
Oh, der lebt noch. Die werden jetzt gebasht.
Das ist die richtige Position für den Kram.
Stimmt, ich bin ein Gelehrter. Magier.
Ihr werdet dieses kranke Spektakel sofort stoppen. Ich will nicht studieren, sondern das Land von seinem Fluch befreien.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich tendiere die einfach zu bashen, aber dann verpassen wir wahrscheinlich irgendwas.
Okay, die greift mich an, dann kann ich sie auch so bashen.
Ja, Carla, das frage ich mich auch.
Okay.
Blablabla.
Die werden jetzt sowas von destroyed gleich.
Lasst uns euch heilen. Alles klar.
Die Schwestern ihre Instrumente ansehen. Okay, das können wir ja noch machen, aber dann...
Ihre Klingen sind unnötig. Für gute Operationen ist mehr Training erforderlich. Alles klar, ich weiß Bescheid.
Überzeugen. Ja, da bräuchte ich Will für.
Okay, Religion.
Meistens werden die Fights dann ein bisschen einfacher, aber das Spiel ist eh nicht schwer. Also insofern easy.
Schars Beistand darf nur den Willen gewährt werden. Okay, das findet Shadowheart sicherlich gut, wenn ich mich mit Schar Gedöns auskenne.
Wie? Nicht? Shadowheart approves.
Wie es weitergehen soll. Ich mache euch jetzt platt.
Okay, ich vermute mal, man kann die überzeugen wegzugehen, dass man nur noch einen bekämpfen muss, anstatt alle.
Warum üben sie sich nicht gegenseitig an sich, um ihr Können zu verbessern? Das ist eine gute Antwort, Gail.
In all meinen Jahren des Lernens habe ich nie einen besseren Lehrer als das Vorbild gefunden. Ja, das wäre auch nicht schlecht.
Und ich habe sogar Advantage drauf.
Nein. Nein. Nope. Okay, jetzt greifen sie mich wahrscheinlich an.
Nee.
Ja. Okay, war klar. Will, was machst du da oben? Der ist ja sonst wo.
Okay. Wisst ihr, was das Beste ist? Hm. Ich hätte eigentlich gesagt Fireball.
Aber dann geht der Patient auch mit drauf.
Was mache ich denn da jetzt?
Das wäre schon enorm praktisch. So schön, wie die zusammen. Okay, wir CC'n die.
Hypnotic Pattern. Das ist das richtig gute Move. Die stehen alle zusammen.
Sehr nice. Oh. Na, nur zwei erwischt. Aber immerhin, der Patient ist jetzt erstmal egal.
Gail, ich habe gedacht, du kannst ein bisschen weiter.
Okay, Will. Ich würde sagen, da ist der Patient wieder dead, Gail. Aber das würde schon Damage machen.
Vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht probiert Will die auch nochmal zu CC'n.
Das wäre natürlich extrem nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Also normalerweise sollte die hier das nicht aufgehoben werden, selbst wenn die jetzt fehlschlägt.
Gucken. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in Baldur's Gate 3 so funktioniert.
Sehr schön. Ja, jetzt können wir uns schön einzeln rauspicken.
Hey, nicht wegrennen. Nicht wegrennen. Da bleiben.
So, ich würde sagen, diesmal gehen wir zuerst auf den Boss.
Zumindest sollten wir immer Nahkämpfe am Boss dran haben.
Dass der Disadvantage kriegt auf irgendwelche Fernangriffe.
Hallo? Jetzt. Nur bis jetzt.
Baldur's Gate 3 für Neueinsteiger. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das Spiel ist nicht schwer. Da kommst du gut rein.
Man muss sagen, das Kampfsystem ist gut gemacht.
Es hat nicht alle Feinheiten der Vorlage, dafür aber jede Menge anderer Sachen zusätzlich.
Du wirst schon klarkommen. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Zumal um 2.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.000.
Auf jeden Fall.
Zumal du im Zweifelsfall auch auf Mittel oder Leicht spielen kannst, dann ist wirklich kein Problem.
Also, ich spiele hier auf dem Höchsten und das ist auch schon nicht sonderlich schwer.
Okay.
So, Shadow... Ne, Moment. Kalak, Kalak, du fängst jetzt mal an hier.
Wie? Nicht genügend. What?
Okay, Kalak. Paladin, jetzt kannst du mal zeigen, was du kannst.
Gegen irgendwelche untote Viecher.
Sobald die hier rauskommen, gibt es...
Ne, Kalak. Du gehst dahin.
So. Sobald die hier rauskommen, gibt es noch Turn Undead von Shadowheart obendrauf.
Die sollten eigentlich den ganzen Fight nicht viel machen.
Bonusaktion haben wir nicht.
Bei Fehlschlag verbraucht kein Zauberplatz. Okay.
30% ist halt echt nicht viel.
Okay, das ist ein Boss. Scheiß drauf. Wir machen, wir machen das.
Wir machen den Bonusdamage aus. Dann sind wir nämlich bei 55%. Da haben wir noch ganz gute Chancen.
Hab ich noch irgendwas, um das zu debuffen?
Da kriegt Kalak Damage. Das wollen wir nicht.
Kann ich das irgendwie noch debuffen, das Viech?
Äh, sieht nicht so aus.
Ich mein, ich könnte probieren, ob ich Advantage kriegen kann, wenn ich hier treffe.
Aber das hat bloß 40%. Mäh.
Mäh. Kalak, hau einfach drauf.
Auf gut Glück.
55%, die meinen sollte doch gehen.
Bam! Ah, shit.
Und bam! Immerhin.
Wie jetzt? Warum konnte ich nicht auswählen, ob ich smiten will?
Ach, Moment. Das ist schon ein...
Das heißt auf Deutsch, göttliches Niederstrecken.
Jetzt ergibt das auch Sinn.
Das muss ich überhaupt nicht auswählen. Das kann ich...
Da werde ich bei jedem Treffer gefragt, ob ich es nicht auslösen will.
Okay. Du machst jetzt das, was du am besten kannst.
Nämlich Level 4.
Spelt Guardians.
Moment. Level 4, Spirit Guardians.
Äh?
Spirit Guardians, Level 4?
Ach, hier kann ich es auswählen.
Ja. So.
Als Bonusaktion...
kommst du nicht nah genug dran, oder, Shadowheart?
Wieder hoch.
Das müsste reichen.
Nice! Hat gereicht.
Hat Damage bekommen.
Okay.
So, die sollten noch, die sollten noch ein Zug hypnotisiert sein.
Da können wir jetzt mal ordentlich Damage machen.
Ist der immun gegen irgendwas? Untersuchen.
Resistenzen gegen Feuer. Ah, das suckt aber.
Dann...
darf der jetzt Damage machen.
Wie jetzt? Unterbrochen? Okay.
Was? Zack!
Kannst du auch ohne Kampf lösen? Dachte ich mir.
Aber ich hatte keinen Bock drauf, da weiter mit denen zu diskutieren.
Okay. Gale?
Du... Moment. Konzentriert sich Gale schon auf irgendwas?
Okay. Gale konzentriert sich auf Hypnotic Pattern.
Die sind...
Die kommen im nächsten Zug raus.
Oder haben die noch einen Zug?
Jetzt finde ich, dass die Anzeige immer ein bisschen schwierig steht.
Zwar 1, aber wann sind denn die dran?
Die kommen jetzt. Okay.
Dann nächste Runde. Dann darf der nächste Runde was beschwören.
Dann macht der Haste auf Kalec, dass Kalec den das nächste, nächste Runde einfach krass bashen kann.
Kriege ich mit Haste auf Stufe 4
zwei Targets, wenn man das abcastet.
Wird dieser Zauber höherem Grad gewirkt, so hat dies keine zusätzlichen Vorteile.
Das ist aber eigentlich nicht so.
Ich bilde mir ein, Haste abcastet, hat ein weiteres Target normalerweise.
Was macht denn das?
Haste.
Irgendwas.
Ist ja auch egal. Ist anscheinend nicht so.
Na dann abcasten wir Haste natürlich nicht.
Woher du das weißt? Naja.
Weil ich das selbst spiele.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob das
in den Regeln steht, dass Haste abcastet
ein zweites Target bringt oder ob das einfach eine Auslegung ist.
Aber ich glaube normalerweise bringt Haste abcastet ein zweites Target.
Okay, Kalec kriegt Haste. Perfekt.
Was spielst du selber? Dindy? Ja.
So richtig oldschool shit.
Aber weder on stream noch irgendwie sonst wie was.
Seit wann?
Ach, seit fünf Jahren oder so.
Und ich habe auch die alten Games alle schon durchgespielt.
Aber das war ja, also Baldur's Gate 1 und 2, das war glaube ich noch
Second Edition, worauf das basierte.
Das ist jetzt eine sehr freie Interpretation von
Fifth Edition Regeln.
So, Haste passt.
Äh, was macht er?
Das Ziel muss ein, was?
Der Chirurg belebt den Leichnam einer seiner Krankenschwestern wieder.
Wait a minute.
Was will er denn da wiederbeleben?
Äh, auf, auf wen?
Auf wen castet er das? Von denen lebt doch keiner mehr.
Schwester? Welche?
Wer ist Schwester?
Wie, welche?
Wer ist Schwester Inessa?
Wer zum Teufel ist Schwester Inessa?
Ist das, ist das die, ist das die vom Eingang oder?
Egal, ich, ich counter das mal.
Ich will nicht, dass der noch mehr wiederbelebt.
Machst du RL-Stills?
Nein, wir spielen online.
RL-Stills!
Glaubst du selbst nicht, dass ich RL-Stills mache?
Äh, nein.
Ich mache nicht RL-Stills.
Man kann das relativ gut online spielen.
Es gibt ein paar Seiten.
Das hier dürfte, glaube ich, somit die bekannteste sein.
Ja, guck.
Da kannst du hier, kannst du hier zusammen spielen.
RL-Stills, das wäre es jetzt auch gewesen.
Warst schon schockiert, kann ich verstehen.
Wait, ich bin fehlgeschlagen.
Ein Spell-Counter ist fehlgeschlagen.
Jetzt wird es aber langsam.
Okay, Schwester Inessa ist eigentlich so gut wie dead, gell?
Hallo?
Hund!
Was ist mit dir los?
So, du fliegst in die Mitte.
Was du im Zweifelsverlauf beide damage machen kannst, wenn sie wegrennen.
Ja, excellent, excellent.
Ja, aber nicht so viel Schaden.
Oh.
Nein, nein, lass Gale in Ruhe.
Lässt du meinen Wizard in Ruhe?
Hau ab!
Okay, Shadowheart macht jetzt damage.
Shadowheart könnte übelst damage.
Okay, das hebe ich, das hebe ich mir auf.
Das hebe ich mir auf.
Ähm.
So.
Dann, konzentriert sich Shadowheart gerade auf irgendwas?
Äh, nicht konzentrieren, hat sie irgendwie...
Ne, passt.
Spiritual Weapon, zack.
Und jetzt darfst du da hin.
Und damage machen auf beide.
Perfekt.
Schwester Inessa ist down.
Das Viech...
Ah ja, komm.
Gift, kann man Untote hier vergiften?
Würde mich wundern.
Aber wir können es ja mal probieren.
Ne, ne, komm, das wird nichts bringen.
Hau einfach mal drauf.
Okay.
Tatsächlich...
Man kann untoten Gift damage machen hier.
Okay, nice.
Okay, Kalak, jetzt gibts aufs Maul.
80%.
Die macht jetzt Massive Damage.
Die darf viermal angreifen.
Der kriegt...
Der kriegt reingeprügelt.
Ich kann mir vieles vorstellen,
aber nicht, wie du dich in RL mit Leuten triffst und Roleplay machst.
Ne, da hast du recht.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Alter, Kalak hat ihm gerade 250 TP oder so abgezogen.
So muss das sein.
So, jetzt wird es natürlich ein bisschen kritisch,
wenn die hier unten aus dem CC kommen.
Da müssen sich meine Wizards erstmal ordentlich rumteleportieren,
dass sie nicht drankommen.
Okay, die Viecher sind alle...
weg.
Okay.
Versuche ich die nochmal zu CC'n?
Ich meine, ich kriege drei Stück rein.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich am besten,
bis ich den Boss weg habe.
Oder wir probieren es mal mit Turn Undead.
Ne, wir versuchen die nochmal zu CC'n.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich am besten sein.
Nice.
Okay, die...
Ach, shit.
Ich habe keine Spell Slots mehr.
Haben wir da irgendwie oben drauf oder so?
Ich muss auf jeden Fall weg.
Ne, ne, so nicht.
So, perfekt, Will.
Will, Will, mach's gut.
Okay.
Gail, was machst denn du jetzt?
Nebelwolk? Was habe ich da für einen Schrott ausgerissen?
Ha, aber Gail konzentriert sich auf Haste.
Er kann kein Invisibility-Zeug machen.
Ja, Gail, mach einfach ein bisschen Damage, würde ich sagen.
Mach einfach ein bisschen Damage.
Ach, Mist.
Ah, ich habe es vergessen, die sind ja feuerimmun.
Oder feuerresistent.
Ja, doof.
Gail, du willst genau hier hin.
Beste.
Was zum...
Gail!
Alter, was machst du da?
Du sollst hier hin.
Bester Move von dem Typ.
Bester Move.
Er ist mal in Range gerannt, um sich hinten zu schützen.
Und dann wieder weg.
Hoffentlich hat er Haste nicht verloren.
Dann hätte ich jetzt gekotzt.
Oh, der macht gut Damage.
Okay, die sind noch hypnotisiert.
Alles gut.
Der Hund macht...
Oh, zwei Damage.
Huiuiui.
Schwester Anja.
Ja, renn mal Will hinterher.
Sehr gut, mach das mal.
Oh, wait a minute.
Run?
Das ist aber fies, dass die da rankommt.
Okay.
Shadowheart, du gehst einfach nur ran.
Du hast genug First Level Spell Slots.
Treffer, please.
Fuck.
Damage?
Okay, Kala wird den jetzt bashen.
Oh, zwei TP noch.
Dead.
Kill the surgeon before he performs...
Okay, wir haben irgendwas unlockt.
Alles gut.
So, wir müssen mal Will zur Hilfe kommen.
Der wird verfolgt von zwei wild gewordenen und toten Krankenschwestern.
Können wir noch einen Fernkampfangriff machen auf irgendwas?
Irgendwie so?
Ah, shit.
Können wir noch irgendeinen Fernkampfangriff auf die machen?
Auf die alle?
Ah, shit.
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Die schieß ich nicht an, die sind ja noch zwei Runden CC'ed.
Ja, Spiritual Weapon, toll.
Kommt nicht sonderlich weit.
Sieht schon sehr ähnlich zu Divinity All Chains in 2 aus.
Ja, ist es auch.
Aber, also, man merkt, dass es die gleiche Engine ist.
Vom Gameplay her nicht wirklich.
Es ist nicht wirklich ganz getreu umgesetzt, das Regelwerk.
Aber es ist ziemlich weit weg von Divinity.
Okay, Will, du hast echt ein Problem.
Du musst hier weg.
Will, Will, please, lauf mal ohne...
Wait a minute, ich habe eine noch bessere Idee.
Will, du versteckst dich jetzt einfach.
Unsichtbarkeit.
Will, versteck dich.
Wait a minute.
Will, versteck dich mal.
Beste.
What?
Wait a minute.
Okay, irgendwie hat das Game gelaggt.
Ich dachte, es funktioniert nicht.
Okay.
Ah, ich hätte noch hüpfen sollen.
So, jetzt können die Wills zumindest schon mal nicht bashen.
Es sei denn, die sehen Unsichtbare,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass so 0815 Random untote Unsichtbare sehen können.
Wait, das ist Konzentration?
Wo stand das?
Fuck, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Da könnte einen das Game ja mal warnen.
Ich dachte, dass die normale Unsichtbarkeit Konzentration ist.
Ich dachte, das ist irgendein Spezialding.
Jetzt ist nämlich mein CC auf die Viecher weg,
weil sich Will nicht mehr auf den Zauber konzentriert.
Okay, das war jetzt doof.
Na dann, scheiß drauf.
Nee, geht ja nicht.
Hier drauf?
Gib ihm.
Oh, der hat aber nicht so viel Damage gemacht.
Gehst du weg?
Oh, die weiß schon gar nicht, das Game laggt.
Die weiß schon gar nicht, was sie machen soll.
Wir müssen uns alle bei Shadowheart sammeln.
Shadowheart hat richtig guten AE-Damage auf alles.
Ey, die kann weiterrennen als die andere.
Anzeige ist raus.
Das Game laggt?
Guck mal, das weiß nicht, was es machen soll.
Okay, Kratzer, du machst das hier.
Schön in die Mitte hüpfen.
Oh, random Damage.
Egal, macht es eh nicht aus.
Ja, Schwester Anja sucht Will.
Findet ihr nicht?
Nee, nee, nee, Will ist überhaupt nicht mehr da.
Gut.
Und jetzt geht Shadowheart Damage machen hier.
Kann die vorher noch irgendwas anderes Sinnvolles machen?
Was Kast...
Ich meine, die hat noch ihre ganzen Spells, Leute.
Was Kast... Ich meine, die hat noch ihre ganzen Spells, Leute.
Hm.
Joa.
Könnten Damage machen ein bisschen.
TP, brauchen wir eigentlich alles nicht.
Wir können...
Wir können Turn Undead machen.
Das machen wir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch.
Gehen jetzt hier hin.
Und jetzt machen wir Turn Undead.
Ja.
25% nur.
Ja, kann jeder Cleric,
wenn das funktioniert
und die nicht widerstehen,
dann müssen sie wegrennen.
Mal gucken, wie das in Baldur's Gate 3 gelöst ist.
Vertreiben.
Die betroffene Kreatur muss sich von der Kreatur entfernen,
die sie vertrieben hat.
Ja, genau.
Das ist top.
Gut.
Sehr schön.
Nice.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
so wirklich...
Eigentlich ist es ziemlich egal,
weil Kallak wird die hier jetzt one-shotten.
Und danach wird sie die hier one-shotten.
Also eigentlich egal.
Und danach wird sie hoffentlich noch
die hier vielleicht nicht one-shotten,
aber zumindest ordentlich Damage machen.
Ja.
Jetzt sind sie gleich alle dead.
Oh, das kann doch hochfliegen.
Hallo, fliegen, please.
Okay, Will,
plaste die weg, die Alte.
Dead.
Okay, das war doch ein bisschen anstrengender,
als ich gedacht habe.
Schwester Clara, was hast du denn dabei?
Ein Bohrer?
Noch...
Kein Bohrer, eine Spritze?
Leute, ich muss gleich auf...
Ich muss morgen früh aufstehen und nach Frankfurt fahren.
Moment, das ist was, was man aus...
Das ist eine Waffe,
die man ausrüsten kann.
Das ist ein Kurzschwert.
Nun gut, mit sehr viel,
aber wirklich sehr viel Fantasie
geht das als Kurzschwert durch.
Ups.
So, was hat denn der Chirurg am Start
für schöne Items?
Gampert, danke.
Hm.
Die verdorbene Macht vernichten.
Ganz so hart ist Gale auch nicht drauf.
Übrigens,
nein.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das so einfach ist.
dass die Alles-Kenn-Fraktion
leben wird.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das so einfach ist.
dass die Alles-Kenn-Fraktion
leben wird.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass die Alles-Kenn-Fraktion
leben wird.
receptive.
life
Zauber casten kann. Das Weave, das ist irgendwie so eine Substanz, die es überall gibt und Magier
können die halt formen und verwenden. Fragt mich nicht, so krass lore-fest bin ich da nicht, aber
Weave ist halt diese in-game, in-lore-Erklärung, warum Zauberer zaubern können. Nicht alle,
nicht alle. Bei Warlocks ist es was anderes und bei Sorcerer ist es auch was anderes.
Sorcerer werden geboren mit Magie und Warlocks müssen mit irgendeinem Dämon, Teufel, was auch
immer, irgendein Pakt abschließen, dass sie casten können. Was tatsächlich relativ, relativ coole
Roleplay-Möglichkeiten gibt, wenn man Warlocks spielt. Ja die erklären nicht so viel in dem
Spiel. Auch diese ganze Geschichte mit, dass dein Beschützer, den du da hast, ja um jetzt nicht so
viel zu spoilern, dass der da irgendwie im Weltall hängt. Versteht man auch nicht so richtig, wenn
man, also man muss ehrlich sagen, diese Multiverse-Geschichte von D&D ist etwas wir. So mit
diesen 100 verschiedenen Ebenen und manche die sich überlagern und manche nicht. Also da merkst
du, dass die irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 30 Jahre Lore-Historie haben und am Anfang nicht so genau
wussten, was sie da gemacht haben. Da passt so einiges nicht zusammen. Aber insgesamt eine Sache
finde ich wirklich cool. Sie haben sich ziemlich gut dran gehalten. Wie gesagt, ich bin nicht der
Über-Lore-Kenner, aber ich spiele das schon eine Weile und so ein paar Sachen weiß ich. Sie haben
es schon ganz cool gemacht. Und auch viele Sachen, die man wiedererkennt. Okay, also wir läutern
natürlich den Leichnam. Wobei, ich save mal. Ich hoffe, dass Shadowheart approved, weil Shadowheart
ein Cleric ist und die sicherlich nichts mit irgendwelchen untoten Mächten zu tun haben will.
Allerdings ist Shadowheart ja ein Cleric of Sha und die stehen auf dunkles Zeug. Also keine Ahnung,
wir läutern den Leichnam. Ich hoffe, Shadowheart approves.
Mystra ist die Magie-Göttin. Und da freut er sich. Guck mal, da ist er happy. Schlüssel,
Chirurgen-Amulett. Lebenender kritischer Treffer. Einmal pro lange Rast kann der Träger,
wenn er einen kritischen Treffer gegen einen Humorin hat, zwei Züge lang. Da würde ich mich
nicht drauf verlassen. Ein Amulett-Slot. Warum ist das ein Bade, der Chirurg? Jetzt ist der andere
aufgewacht. Okay, ich hoffe, wir können den Patienten irgendwie noch heilen. Schauen wir mal.
Erstmal muss Schwester Julia noch gelootet werden. Es ist deutlich wichtiger, als zu gucken,
wie es dem Patienten geht. Warum ist das so? Ist das eine Falle? Nee, das buggt einfach. Die
Leiter buggt. Okay. Äh, what? Will! Will, du willst mir jetzt wirklich erzählen,
du musstest die Leiter hochklettern, um da unten an die Flasche zu kommen. Ja,
klar. Obviously. Man weiß ja immer nicht so genau, wie das Game sich verhält. Also,
wird operiert. Ich würde ja sagen, ich heile den. Oder ich mache das, was normalerweise gegen das
meiste hilft. Aber man weiß ja nicht, was das Game jetzt möchte. Man hätte den Patienten bestimmt
retten können, wenn man den Doktor früher angegriffen hätte. Ja, ist ja gut. Das hört
ja gar nicht mehr auf. What the fuck? Haben wir es heute noch mal? Die Fesseln lösen. Ob das so
eine gute Idee ist? Jetzt rennt er weg. Hey, da bleiben. Ja, okay. Keine Ahnung, dann. Alles klar,
ich renne dir mal hinterher. Alter, bleibst du da? Da ist er wieder. Hey! Ey, jetzt ist er weg.
Der hat sich einfach wegteleportiert. People run hat er gemacht. Okay, hier unten ist irgendwo
ein Teleporter. Da gehe ich jetzt aber nicht hin, weil, Leute, ich muss ins Bett. Angeblich ist
doch hier ein Teleporter gewesen. Vielleicht hier oben? Schnell nochmal kurz looten. Nix mehr da
zum looten. Okay, vielleicht hier oben noch. Irgendwo muss ja was sein. Hier ist ein Schlüssel.
Top. Handschuhe vergiften. Wenn du Giftschaden bewegst, müssen die... war ich nicht. Also ich
hoffe ja immer noch auf einen Teleporter, dass ich hier einfach wieder zurückkomme. Aber anscheinend
ist da nichts. Aber ich habe ja jetzt schon Schlüssel. Okay, ich gucke jetzt hier oben noch
schnell, ob es da einen Teleporter gibt. Oh ne, der Dude. Ist das ein Teleporter? Das ist ein Teleporter!
Poggers! Okay, ich will nicht mit Raphael reden. Da kommt irgendwelcher Story-Krempel jetzt. Ich
mache jetzt G-Bait. Ich stelle es mich jetzt an Raphael vorbei. Perfekt, aktiviert. Und jetzt
teleportieren wir zurück. Oh wait, da teleportiert nur Carla. Das ist aber doof. Raphael ausgetrickst.
Mit dem reden wir dann morgen. Outmoved. Okay, nice. Progress gemacht. Alles klar, Leute. Schön,
dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich kann das Game wirklich nur wärmstens empfehlen. Also wer Bock
hat, wieder auf ein ordentliches RPG. Und scheiß drauf, dass das nicht so hundertprozentig der
Vorlage gerecht wird. Gerade das Kampfsystem. Dafür gibt es sehr viele eigene Sachen, die es so in der
Vorlage nicht gibt. Also wenn man natürlich der super D&D-Purist ist, dann ist das nichts. Aber
eigentlich ist es für jeden, der RPGs mag. Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis morgen. Macht's gut. See you.